bonsoir club blanchemaison merci de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
qu'est ce que vous retenez de la prise
de parole de vladimir poutine au forum
de davos
je crois que c'est une intervention
importante
d'abord parce que comme vous l'avez dit
lanières poutine n'a pas participé au
forum davos depuis 2009
en deuxième lieu parceque il a fait une
analyse très précise de la crise
économique actuelle due à la pandémie du
coc u19 qui convergent absolument avec
ce que disent tous les grands
responsables mondiaux
que ce soient des responsables
politiques ou le fmi ou la banque
mondiale
en troisième lieu parce qu'il a pris la
défense des organisations multilatérales
en disant qu'elle était essentielle pour
résoudre les problèmes du temps et puis
enfin parce qu'il appuie les propos très
positifs sur l'europe
alors vous avez fait je crois très bon
résumé dans votre sujet de la du
diagnostic que réduire poutine peau cela
sur la crise économique et il a en effet
beaucoup insisté sur le fait que les
inégalités croissantes à l'intérieur des
états et entre les états étaient
extrêmement dommageable parce que elle
poussait à l'intérieur des états à la
montée des extrêmes extrême gauche et
extrême droite et entre les états à la
poussée du nationalisme tout cela
générateur de conflits et par conséquent
il a appelé en effet à prendre des
politiques qui permettent de réduire ces
inégalités pour lutter contre la
tendance actuelle il a aussi parlé bien
sûr des cafards qui viennent en
concurrence avec les états et qu'il
convient maintenant de réguler par
conséquent qu'il y ait une régulation
par les états ou par une instance
internationale de leur activité par
ailleurs il a appelé à une relance de
l'économie en faisant appel à
l'entrepreneuriat en faisant appel à la
société civile
en faisant appel aux forces vives des
différentes nations le président russe
qui insiste sur la relation également
entre
russie et l'europe ce rapprochement est
ce qu'il est réaliste alors la libertine
parle de 3par de trois constatations de
trois réalités il dit la russie et
l'europe partagent la même culture
elle partage deuxièmement la même
civilisation et troisièmement elles ont
des intérêts économiques convergent
parce qu'elles sont complémentaires et
d'ailleurs l'union européenne et reste
la première le premier partenaire
économique de la russie
donc pour toutes ces raisons on voit pas
pourquoi il y aurait le moindre divorce
entre la russie et l'union européenne il
a rappelé que dans les années 2000 on
avait discuté d'un espace commun entre
la russie et l'union européenne
il aurait pu se décliner d'ailleurs sur
divers que sur divers aspects la
connaissance l'économie la sécurité
évidemment il a il a ajouté qu' il
fallait être deux pour avancer et que
l'amour devait être partagé ce que c'est
l'expression qui l'a utilisé et que pour
que cela fonctionne il fallait repartir
à zéro c'est adhérer ni réinitialiser
les relations entre
l'europe et la russie et mettre entre
parenthèses les sujets qui fâchent ou
qui nous ont fâché au cours des
dernières années ce qui naturellement
sera sujet à discussion à l'intérieur de
l'union européenne parce que certains
états pensent qu'il est difficile de
mettre entre parenthèses les difficultés
qui sont présentés notamment en ukraine
et que la plupart des états considèrent
qu'il faut de toute façon observé les
internationaux et notamment ceux des
nations-unies il prévoit de respecter
les droits de l'homme comme l'enjeu
maison coville 19 oblige c'est un davos
virtuel à 1 cette année
mais un deuxième se tiendra en mai à
singapour en présentiel cette fois ci
les conditions sanitaires le permettent
de forum économique coup sur coup ça
peut accélérer le dénouement de certains
dossiers
oui peut-être en tout cas ça montre deux
choses ça montre que les gens qui
participent actuellement au forum de
davos attache beaucoup d'importance aux
relations personnelles comme on dit à
davos et comme on dit également à
singapour
le networking tisser les liens tissés
les réseaux et pour cela il faut qu'une
réunion se déroule en présentiel et le
deuxième la deuxième conclusion qu'on
peut tirer de ce rendez-vous de
singapour en mai c'est que le professeur
schwab a voulu sans doute marqué la nuit
d'importance nouvelles de l'asie dans
l'économie mondiale s'est en effet
le virage vers la vie qui a déjà été
marquée par les états unis dans le passé
et par un certain nombre de grands pays
alors est-ce que à singapour on fera des
progrès essentiel c'est possible hier la
chancelière angela merkel a parlé des
vaccins et elle a dit que bien entendu
il fallait que tous les pays et à
l'intérieur des pays toutes les
catégories de la population est un accès
égal aux vaccins on sait bien que ce
n'est pas le cas actuellement puisque
certains pays ont acheté ont préempté
sur le marché des vaccins que d'autres
ont des difficultés à se fournir
et que comme souvent les pays en
développement arrive bon dernier et que
leurs populations se trouve discriminés
contrairement à ce qu'avait promis le
secrétaire général de l'onu
contrairement à ce qu'avait promis
également le directeur général de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
et ceci est un problème important parce
que ils pourraient avoir un ressentiment
important de la part des populations
discriminées par rapport à cette
nouvelle inégalité et puis des
propositions ont été faites
la main tendue du projet du président
poutine à l'europe
et d'ici là il est probable que les
européens verront quelles réponses y est
on peut apporter
il est possible d'apporter une réponse
positive en effet en décidant de mettre
provisoirement entre parenthèses des
sujets qui fâchent ça ne veut pas dire
qu'on est d'accord ça veut dire comme on
dit chez les diplomates que l'on le
bruit tout 18 sur un certain nombre de
sujets et on l'aimé pour un certain
temps de durée indéterminée entre
parenthèses nouveaux progrès sur les
sujets sur lesquels on peut progresser
et il est possible que ce soit le cas
d'ici le mois de mai merci comme
blanchemaison d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
expert en relations internationales